I'm John Healy this is joint work with
Leland McKenna's who you saw I'll give a
dimension reduction talk earlier today
if you missed that talk I'm gonna highly
recommend it it was a lot of fun when it
goes up on YouTube go check it out I've
got to give a quick shout out to another
pair of colleagues here from the Tut who
are shell and ami woulding who are going
to be giving a tutorial on reproducible
data science tomorrow I'd recommend you
drop by that as well so who are we we're
mathematicians and researchers of the
ton Institute for mathematics computing
which little Research Institute in
Ottawa Canada we've recently been
focusing some of our research efforts on
sort of foundational mathematics
underneath machine learning and data
science techniques to that end a while
back we came back on a great clustering
algorithm called HDB scan we figured out
how to make it more efficient and
developed it into an open-source library
that's now been contributed to
scikit-learn contribute I'm gonna talk
to you a little bit today but both how
and why HDB scan works all right to
start with that I'm gonna roll back and
talk about clustering in general so
let's get everyone on the same page
clustering at its heart is about
grouping together data points that are
very similar I'm gonna break that down
by breaking down clustering algorithms
in a way that I find useful and I'm
going to apply Lille and sort of red
star this is gonna be a very high level
I might lie a little bit in this
breakdown but I think it's gonna give
you the right intuition so let's start
off by dividing clustering algorithms
and just to sort of clumps cluster
elements are a naturally break apart
into centroid based or parametric
clustering algorithms or density based
algorithms so
centroid based algorithms are going to
make explicit assumptions or implicit
assumptions about the shape of your
clusters this is going to allow them to
work on very small amounts of data very
well which is a really nice feature
density based clustering is going to
allow your data to define the shape of
your clusters that's going to require a
lot more data to be very effective at
working so now we've got a nice great
hold on now
I got that wrong we shouldn't break them
down that way that doesn't the right way
to break them down is flat versus
hierarchical clustering that's a way
better way to divide it sorry so this is
about sort of complex
city of resolution flat clustering gives
you a single grouping or partitioning of
your data while hierarchical clustering
returns sort of sets of nested
relationships between your data which is
a much nicer way to think about
clustering algorithm all right hold on
what if we got a two-dimensional
partitioning of our clustering
algorithms where we can have flat
centroid based flat density based
hierarchical centroid based and
hierarchical density based that might be
a nice way to group a nice taxonomy of
clustering algorithms together
I'm gonna give you a quick whirlwind
tour through these four cells starting
with flat sort of centroid based or
parametric clustering algorithms so
these two of the most common algorithms
in this space are k-means which most
people have probably heard of or
Gaussian mixture models so as I
mentioned these have either an explicit
or an implicit assumption about the
shape of your clusters so that's gonna
require you to have an a prior
understanding of what you want your
cluster shapes to be before you choose
your algorithm so this is going to work
really well on small amounts of data
it's gonna work in low dimensions where
you can visualize your data and get an
understanding for the shapes you're
seeing within your data but that's
rarely a situation that I'm in I often
end up dealing with higher dimensional
data where I can't see and don't know
what my data really looks like this is
sort of the situation that I tend to
find myself in higher dimensional
versions of this where Mike clusters
from all sorts of different shapes their
variable densities their variable sizes
k-means and parametric algorithms tend
to perform poorly in these sort of
situations because they're gonna make
the gaussian ball assumption that as
your clusters are sort of high
dimensional spheres now the Gaussian
ball assumption it's lovely in theory
but in my experience it's a little bit
like a spherical cow theoretically very
appealing but rarely occurring in nature
additionally they're gonna make the same
problem have one problem which is a
number of clusters parameter our
resolution parameter that we're gonna
have to fit and if we don't know a lot a
prior I about what's going on with the
data that's gonna be really hard to set
alright that brings us to flat density
based clustering examples here a DB scan
or mean shift algorithm these eliminate
the parametric distribution assumption
made by centroid based methodologies
which is nice
think of these are sort of nonparametric
data-driven versions of the centroid
based methods DB scan or I'll say
density based spatial clustering of
algorithms with noise applications with
noise sorry is a popular density based
costing algorithm it's got some nice
advantages it's fast its robust to noise
it allows for variable shaped clusters
you get the nice advantage here you
don't Saul the points in the gray in the
background
it's a clustering algorithm not a
partitioning algorithm which means it's
not requiring you to put every one of
your points into one of your clusters
which is really nice if you think there
might be actual noise in your data
k-means doesn't have that property and
you can get very variable clusters in
high dimensions without realizing what's
happening fortunately it's got a similar
disadvantage to our previous algorithm
and that the resolution parameter on
this is quite hard to set which leads us
to hierarchical centroid based or
parametric algorithms and these are
specifically a doctrine designed to
address that parameter selection problem
since we don't know a pro RI what the
correct numbers of clusters in are we're
gonna build a sort of a natural
hierarchy over a whole range of our
clustering and use that to try to divine
the correct number so that is often to
be represented as a dendrogram which can
be useful but if you quickly over round
the user so this is a picture of those
clusters splitting up and breaking apart
as it fragments down until you have
every point in their own cluster right
at the bottom and so from this you can
sort of look at it and stir the tea
leaves a little bit and say no there
should be four maybe six maybe eight
clusters I know the answer I want so I'm
gonna pretend that you can Devine six
from looking at this and say oh that's
obvious and that gives you this
clustering but again we see we get hurt
here by the parametric assumption
implicit in what I do there which was
called war
clustering via hierarchical and that
assumption was essentially again the
Gaussian ball it's come back to bite us
again but everyone in this room at this
point says wait John you just told me
how to deal with the Gaussian ball
assumption we do use density based
clustering and you would be right so
that would bring us the hierarchical
density based clustering the big reveal
then of the question mark state should
be scanned shouldn't be a surprise to
anyone who read the title of the top
with you before you came so this is
hierarchical density based spatial
clustering of applications with noise
HTTP scan this is the kind of space you
want to use when you're using density
based clustering to robust to variable
shaped clustering and hierarchical
clustering to be account for the
resolution problem within your data so
HDB scan is a good example of a
hierarchical density based clustering
algorithm let's talk a little bit about
more about that let's talk about higher
density based clustering in general so
I'm going to start with a high-level
motivating description that's gonna give
you an example of a natural way you
might go about constructing hierarchical
density based algorithm alright let's go
back to that dataset we were looking at
before this is DB scan as I said before
the hard thing with DB scan is a
slightly unintuitive parameter called
Epsilon finding the epsilon that's gonna
fit your data it can be a little bit of
work
so let's look what happens when we bury
that epsilon parameter for very small
values of epsilon really a little tiny
clusters and most of your data defined
as noise in the background we're gonna
increase epsilon the background noise
get sucked into your clusters some of
your clusters get merged together we
increase epsilon again more background
noise get sucked in your clusters get
over merged and eventually this will
merge everything into one single massive
cluster this is easy to deal with if
you're dealing with two-dimensional data
you can do the advanced eyeball exam and
you can say ah I found the freight
parameter I've looked a lot of pretty
pictures and high dimensional data that
gets a lot harder to do but it turns out
that as epsilon decreases
you've got to guarantee that components
are only going to fragment into smaller
clusters are going to break into smaller
stirrers or vanish entirely that's nice
that lets you build a hierarchical tree
which we could represent via dendrogram
and now we can stop here and say haha I
have a hierarchical tree this is what I
present to users I'm going to require
you to do a cut through that tree and
I'm finished exercise to the reader and
I walk away but that's still a bit too
complex for my liking it's a bit too
complex to be useful because these can
get very very complex for large data
very quickly and eventually look like a
big mass of black on your screen so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna simplify
that cluster tree we're gonna prune the
dendrogram back by eliminating any
clusters with less than min points in
them and this is going to get a much
simpler dendogram and then we're gonna
use a cluster selection from this tree
via either a flat cut which we're sort
of comfortable with from before or a
more advanced technique that I'll talk
about a little bit later and that is
going to give us the clustering that I
wanted when I first looked at this data
so this is almost exactly what I wanted
the black points are noise again the
number of clusters looks about right the
clusters are nicely shaped the algorithm
I just described is very roughly HTTP
scan now why does density based
clustering work so let's back up a
moment see what's gonna go on first we
should define what we want a
hierarchical density based algorithm to
do let's define a cluster I'm gonna
define a cluster to mean a connected
component of a level set of a
probability density function of an
underlying and unknown distribution over
what your data samples are drawn
obviously what sorry
I'll back up and take that a little more
slowly with some intuition we're gonna
presume that's an underlying probability
density function over which our samples
of our data are drawn from there are
some areas that are less likely to see
data they're more areas that are more
likely to have data drawn from them you
can color that with a heat map of that
probability density function denser
regions are more likely to see data
showing up then I can draw contour plots
over that or level sets and this is like
a topography map if you've ever seen one
of those you can see the level sets
increasing as your areas get denser we
can take that we can select a
we'll set from that cut it off these
look at the connected parts of those
level sets and see what's closed in this
case we're gonna call each connected
part a cluster that's gonna result in
our clustering
everything not last sued I'm gonna call
background noise fine I'm done I have a
great clustering algorithm except I
don't quite so what's the difference
between what I just described and a
clustering algorithm first off we don't
know that probability is a function that
I drew initially this is the underlying
problem of density based algorithm says
how you go about estimating that
probability density function second how
did I choose that level set a hint is
carefully by hand knowing the answer I
wanted ahead of time so that I can do a
nice talk in reality this is the problem
that the hierarchical component of our
algorithm is going to try to deal with
which level set should I choose
and lastly we'd like an algorithm to be
efficient so we can do crazy things for
a hundreds or thousands of points but if
we want to scale to millions of points
we have to start talking about what we
can do with good computational
efficiency and what I just described is
naively not computationally efficient so
what can we do if we've got no we know
what we should be doing
let's see what's computationally
feasible to do all right
first we're gonna have to locally
approximate that density said there are
two problems let's deal with the first
one so how are we gonna do this in a
fast efficient way and fast inefficient
in this case means locally without
looking at all of our data at any given
point in time all right where's what DB
scan does it's got two parameters
epsilon and min points it's gonna draw a
bunch of balls of radius epsilon around
all of our data then it's gonna say hey
if you have more than min points in your
epsilon ball I'm gonna declare your
debts this is going to be very fast to
compute it's all very local and it's
point counting in very small local
regions now but what if we don't want a
declaration of dense or not dense what
if instead we'd like an estimate of the
density well what if I draw circles of
whatever radius would enclose
men points many points and so now in
other words what radius would I have to
take before DB scan declared a point to
be dense I'm going to draw those circles
I'm going to color code those circles
with smaller circles being darker
representing denser regions of space
lighter circles being larger lest it
dense regions of space now I'm going to
take those colors I'm going to map them
on the points and now what I have is a
very fast to compute local point
estimate of the probability density
function at each of my points for my
data set so now we've done a fast way to
compute the density how we going to
compute the level sets all right the
intuition here is that the connected
components of a level sets are gonna
form a tree so that's probably best seen
with a pretty picture even an animation
yes it worked so as your required
density to be included drops your
background points start getting added
into your clusters and so as you
encounter new branches these things
going to merge together you can think of
this as the water level dropping and
islands of your cluster appearing and as
they drop down a new islands will appear
and other islands of your data will be
merging together at the base when your
density drops completely all of the
points under a single massive cluster
all right we can play the same game with
our data points you can picture slowly
expanding circles around each of the
data points as the density decreases as
the points become dense under the
density we're gonna color them in and
we're gonna merge circles when their
components meet you watch the tree form
and it's going to end in a single root
and that would be fine if we were
dealing with Euclidean distance the key
point here is that we're not dealing
with a pure Euclidean distance we're
dealing with something called
neutral reach ability distance with an
HDTV scan and all of that is saying that
before you can connect to components
they don't have to only be closed in
Euclidean space
they also have to be
dents so we'd like to code both of those
conditions into a single distance and
that's going to be mutual reachability
distance in this case that's essentially
writing a new distance functions that's
the max of the distance between the
points and each of their distance to
their case nearest neighbor their
capital is just distance to the case
nearest neighbor for a point so this has
the effect of pushing sparse points away
from the rest of our data but it's also
what's going to make a flat cut through
the tree we're gonna build equivalent to
running DB scan for a particular
parameter Epsilon there's a little bit
of a foreshadowing here it turns out
that this satisfies the triangle
inequality which will come up later in
the talk and bring us great joy well
bring me great joy at the very least all
right so now we've approximated the
level sets of a tree you might want to
track the flat clustering from that
again here's a dendrogram we could do a
flat cut across it that would be
equivalent to running DB scan for a
given epsilon parameter we could be done
but we would like to do something a
little bit smarter so we're gonna do
that condensed dendrogram again and
we're gonna prune out any of those
clusters of size less than min points
and the intuition here is that as a
cluster is decaying any time a small one
or two points ie any point less than min
points or any number of them fall out of
a cluster I'm just saying the clusters
shrinking I'm not letting you spawn a
new cluster I'm not breaking off a
single two new cluster and a single two
new cluster cluster shrink unless they
hit a point that splits them into two
large chunks and you get a much more
simplified representation of the
dendrogram coming out of that here I've
colored the dendrogram by the size of
the cluster and I've also done the width
of those bars based on the size of the
clusters so you can see what's happening
as those clusters fade away and then
vanish so now we need to select a
clustering from this a flat clustering
would work but we would like to find
something a little bit more natural
that's not going to force you to go and
look at this dendrogram every time you
want to find out the natural clustering
so
we're gonna think talk about is
persistence of the clusters so we want
the clusters that live for a really long
time in this density plot and are really
large and have lots of our data and
that's going to amount to just
maximizing the amount of ink we have on
this page subject to the constraint that
if you select one of these clusters
you're not allowed to select any of
their descendants and we're done you get
a very natural clustering falling out
immediately from that and that's the
clustering I showed you earlier and
that's HDTV scan so this is the HTTP
scan algorithm it was described and a
couple of papers by compellable avi
sander and Civic it's a great advance in
clustering I can't say enough good
things about it it should be amongst the
first clustering algorithms I think
anyone should run on their data
unfortunately even though it's a
fantastic cutting-edge algorithm it's in
squared which could limit its
applicability if you have large amounts
of data so what can we do we can try to
make it fast all right how are we gonna
go about making this fast the key here
is to realize that under the hood this
closely resembles a Sinkin single
linkage computation which can be reduced
to a minimal spanning tree computation
prims algorithm one of the best
algorithms around for computing minimal
spanning trees that's great but it's
only true in the midst number of edges
is a small multiple of the number of
vertices in your graph unfortunately we
have a complete graph with n squared
edges and as a result that's not going
to be fast or efficient for this
particular case what other alternative
algorithms do we have that we might make
use of so there's another algorithm
called budova cos algorithm so booter of
cos algorithm on a graph conceptually
can be thought of as a parallel version
of prims so what we're gonna do is
forever we're gonna start with all the
vertices and their own separate
components and then for each component
and we're gonna find the shortest edge
that touches that component that isn't
in it are in it in a component we're
gonna merge those components we're gonna
repeat over and over the process until
we're left with a single component
and that single component is going to be
the minimal spanning tree of your graph
the algorithm is a log V which means we
aren't doing any better than prim so far
but as I mentioned before this is a de
general graph we've got points points in
space so this is a spatial graph so
what's what's Berta's algorithm look
like on a spatial graph all right start
with every point in its own component
we're in a query each point for its
nearest neighbor that is not within the
component for each component lad in the
smallest edge will merge will rinse will
repeat we'll end up with a single big
component and that will be the minimal
spanning tree it sounds like almost what
I just said earlier except I use a
slightly different word I said nearest
neighbor not shortest edge so if we can
find a way to speed up nearest neighbor
computations then we can speed up our
whole algorithm and we're good to go
well as everybody knows if you want to
speed up a nearest neighbor query you
look at spatial indexing trees fun so
basic idea of spatial indexing tree is
that you're going to recursively
partition your space into separate
little regions and then when you want to
query a new point you just drop it down
your tree until you hit a leaf node and
then you only actually have to compare
the distance of your new point to all
the points within the leaf node because
you've got bounds on the distance you
can be away from any point within a
given region that's spatial indexing
trees they're well known they do
wonderful things for you so now the
intuition we've just been described it's
been put into practice by a great paper
by March RAM and gray they actually
provide as good complexity bounds it's
wonderful it's called dual tree bruco
for minimal Euclidean spanning trees
wonderful paper it works for KD trees it
works for cover trees that looks like a
slightly complex complexity bound those
C's are just really small data dependent
constants the Alpha is the inverse
Ackermann function which is if it takes
on values between like three and four
for any values in n ranging from 60 to
10 to the 80 so if you're clustering all
of the data in the universe
it's maybe four otherwise it's a small
constant and you're okay make those
vanish and you're looking at algorithm
which is essentially n log n instead of
N squared now except that thing that
came up last time again mutual reach
ability distance not Euclidean distance
but that's okay because it turns out the
only thing that they required for the
algorithm to work was the triangle
inequality holding and we have the
triangle inequality holding for mutual
reach ability distance so with a little
finagling and a fair amount of technical
finesse you can make the dual tree root
of K algorithm work across mutual reach
ability distance instead of Euclidean
distance and we're good to go so now we
have an algorithm that theoretically
works is in log N and you're saying sure
but those constants might be silly large
and your algorithm could be garbage and
I'm sure it's favor where but no so I
ran experiments so these are scaling
experiments comparing the Python
implementation of HDTV scan that we had
developed in this now and scikit-learn
trip with the base implementation java
implementation of HDTV scan because
we're comparing implementations as well
as algorithms you should take this with
a giant grain of salt maybe a boulder of
salt because the details might not be in
the algorithm they might be in the
actual details of efficient coding
that's okay the only takeaway here is
those lines are wildly different shapes
on the left you have sort of the natural
timings and on the right you have the
log-log plots and those shapes are very
indicative of an N squared algorithm
versus an N log n so it looks like we've
got a practical efficient n log n
algorithm running on our data so you say
ok well you're faster than HDB scan
that's good but I've got lots of other
clucks during algorithms I could use how
do you compare against those that's an
excellent question let's run that
experiment as well so these are grabbing
a whole slew of the algorithms that FSK
learn and this is to minimize any sort
of effect that might come from language
intended effects or base coding
run a whole slew of them you quickly see
that this groups up in a sort of three
natural clumps of algorithms the very
fast ones the bottom medium-speed ones
and the quite slow ones near the top
let's throw out anything but the fastest
ones and then I can scale my number of
data points out farther to the right and
we can see a more interesting comparison
so here HDB scan is the dark green line
to k-means algorithms scikit-learn and
scifi hmm
are in the bottom lines yeah and the
interesting thing here is DB scan is the
blue line so that should be interesting
because I had said earlier that running
HDB scan is equivalent to running DB
scan for every value of Epsilon
that's DB scan run with a single value
of Epsilon and we've managed to get it
faster do the computational tricks that
we're using to speed things up that's
nice but you should take that with a
tiny grain of salt again because DB
scans performance can vary wildly
depending on the epsilon value you chose
it's a really good algorithm it's very
fast it's very solid if you pick epsilon
too small it declares every single one
of your points as noise and it's
blindingly fast it can do nothing really
quickly if you set up salon too big it
grinds to a halt both of those cases are
not fair to DB scan which is a good
algorithm so if you want to compare
against it you need to find the right
parameter that's doing something
meaningful on your data actually compare
against okay the way we got around that
was we said I'm gonna do a massive hyper
parameter search
I'm gonna run h DB scan I'm gonna get a
clustering I'm gonna get that persistent
natural clustering extracted from the
tree then I'm gonna search across a
whole slew of parameters for DB scan and
find the clustering that best matched my
h DB scan clustering and that way I can
guarantee that DB scan is doing
something meaningful with my data once I
found those
going to plot the timings for those
parameter runs against the timings for
an HTTP scan run and the short takeaway
here is the Green Line is HTTP scan the
blue line is DB scan they are performing
very similarly so you can get on
meaningful runs with a single run of h
DB scan all of the epsilon parameters of
DB scan and as a result even if you like
DB scan more than HD V scan you want
this flat cuts the right way to go about
doing it is to build the tree for every
one of them and then choose the cut you
want out of it so there's not a reason
to run DB scan anymore if you want it
run h DB scan and pull the results out
so we've got an accelerated HTTP scan
it's very easy to install
reproducibility matters so all of these
experiments are available in notebooks
or binders you can load them up you can
run them you can play with them
yourselves the interface because it's in
scikit-learn can trim the interface
matches scikit-learn which means if
you've got notebooks or data analyses or
anything like that it's making use of
k-means clustering or hierarchical
clustering or any of the clusterings out
of scikit-learn you can install this and
swap out HTTP those algorithms for HTTP
scan immediately look at the results see
what they do on your data I encourage
you to do that if you like what you see
or don't like what you see give us a
shout we'll be very interested to hear
your experiments and your experiences
with a clustering on your data any
questions
[Applause]
if you go back and look at the metric D
choose looked at which one's the metric
the Chinese he was one yeah sure
reachability distance
have you considered putting weights on
tie on the first two numbers or the last
or just the last one and would that
change anything like um there's like a
five and in front of the T what does
that make sense it would be weird
good you know yeah it would be weird I
would agree you you would no longer be
talking about density you would be
talking about some sort of different
metric right because this is all about
trying to make sure that a point is
dense as well as closed under DB scans
definition of density yeah so you change
the definition no offense exactly yeah
that's me where you could totally yeah
the definition of density is very much a
thing you could yeah thanks no problem
anyone else you mentioned the triangle
inequality a number of times
could you define that sure if I am
particularly dis in this way for a mom
if we are this distance apart and Leland
and I are this distance apart I know
that you two have to be closer to each
other than going through this path so
truck so if that doesn't hold this is a
basic definition of what we would call a
metric space you need this to hold for
any of your intuitions to match up it's
faster to go through a direct route then
to come off here and then go there in
any space that baffles that's the
triangle inequality holding if that's
not true it breaks all of these sort of
abilities to do those spatial trees that
we were talking about does that make
some sense no okay we could grab a
whiteboard afterwards and I can grind
through some more details if you like
so algorithmically if my data is larger
than memory what is the right way to
build a minimum spanning tree not saying
tools and just saying how does one build
the algorithm right my short answer is
to buy a bigger computer that was our
solution my longer asker would be to
talk to a desk developer somewhere and
see if you could work together to get
this built over top of gask I may have
been pandering to the person who asked
the question there no yeah it's hard is
the shorter the very short answer any
more questions of clustering algorithms
sure what where does spectral clustering
fit in there
sure so spectral clustering is flat
parametric so traditional spectral
clustering is going to be done by
inducing the nearest neighbor graph
looking at the laplacian doing an igt
composition embedding that into a low
dimensional space and then running
k-means on that low dimensional data and
so it's a spatial transform followed by
a k-means that's traditional spectral
clustering you could do something
stinkier so if you say I'm willing to
like be spectral ish clustering you
could embed that down into a low
dimensional space and then you could run
higher clustering across it or you could
run something else on and that would
move it out of that category and this is
sort of where dimension reduction and
clustering start intersecting which
makes it a very natural thing to move
from clustering research into you map
research which means you should go see
Leland's talk on the web
Thanks
what are your thoughts on using TST as a
method to make data more visualizable
either before or after using HTTP scan
my short answer is going to be I would
suggest you use you map instead and what
is the American uniform manifold a
uniform manifold approximation and
projection you can pip install you map
easiest way to find that would be if you
want more details on it
Leland gave a sci-fi talk on you map my
GS needs a fine
embedding technique you can do TST and
look at the clusters that come out one
of the issues I have had in practice
with running TST before using HDB scan
is the embeddings I get out of TST are
very often unstable so if I run the
algorithm once and I run it again I get
different clustering out and this
typically makes my end-users very
uncomfortable and it makes them less
they don't trust my clustering as much
and I don't want to inject any of that
noise and I don't want very stable
results so I really want to stable
embedding technique before running a
clustering algorithm is it easy to
explain the main difference between you
map and T is knee know okay but I will
give you a pointer to the slides
immediately afterwards thing it's not in
the short time we have right now I think
we have time for one more question if
anyone has one okay we can thank our
speaker again
you